hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
august 2nd 2021
jesus h christ can you [ __ ] believe
it
oh my god the summer's over i'm almost
oh thank god for global warming summer's
gonna keep going until october
um anyway why can't i [ __ ] hear
myself anymore am i going deaf over here
the numbers seem to be high enough is
there a volume button
what does this do what if i push this
does this do something
yeah i don't know bill what if she
actually read the [ __ ] manual
that could do something what about these
here are these little buttons here
what if i turn the light on what if i
could see
oh there's so many what-ifs you know
it's a lot like writing a script
what if we had the guy do this well gee
i don't know
what if we had him do that oh there's a
volume there's a volume oh and i can
hear myself well that's what happened
all right there you go it was exciting i
actually just did that and i didn't lose
my temper
you owe me [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
so [ __ ] stupid stupid [ __ ] thing
that i don't know how to build
um anyway how are you guys
it's the beginning of august it's
beginning to look a lot
like football season no
can't do that can't skip over america's
past time it's america's
pastime usa usa
major league baseball everybody our
version of cricket
but we get it done in three hours cause
we got [ __ ] to do
unlike you guys with your three-day
[ __ ] games who cares after three days
you know what am i watching a mini i'm
kidding if i was still boozing i'd be
the biggest cricket fan ever
going to the game honey see in three
days going a three-day [ __ ] bender
i thought you just said you're good it
came yeah i was the street it's three
days long
i didn't know that oh well you know i
mean it's in the papers
you know you got the internet the
information's out there
you're mad at me
you know if you tell me you're going to
brunch i know how long that takes if
somebody says i'm going to cricket
uh my first thing well how long does
that take you didn't ask
you didn't ask the questions you needed
to ask
well i don't know i just you know
something it was a great three days how
about you leave it at that
all right so oh billy [ __ ]
bantamweight i'm sorry billy
cruiserweight
super [ __ ] lightweight whatever the
[ __ ] i am billy fat
[ __ ] tits
is uh i'm gonna try to do the elliptical
every
single day to prove that guy wrong on
youtube
cardio burns fat right no i'm gonna
prove that guy [ __ ] wrong
um i also been eating right doing the
right thing
so i don't become a tub of [ __ ]
i was happy when i went to the wedding
was my suits actually i was on the upper
echelon of them fitting me
i'm not saying i didn't put a little
stress on the fasteners
i'm not saying the zipper wasn't like
jesus christ how many times can you do
the electric slide
for the love of [ __ ] christ
um it was amazing
if you guys listened to my [ __ ]
podcast last week last thursday you got
a glimpse into me
of who i really was the amount that i
was freaking out about a wedding where
i'm not even the one getting [ __ ]
married
just because of what a social event it
is and how it just takes me back
to when i was a [ __ ] kid and you know
just growing up in a loner anti-social
[ __ ] environment that all of those
[ __ ] like you know
i actually had to somebody had to teach
me how to talk to a waitress
like they would come over be like hey
would you like any any more juice and
i'd just be like
no and then they walk away my buddy
who waited tables wait dude you know why
were you so harsh to her
and then i was just like you know all
defensive and angry like you think i'm
angry now
back in the day i was just like what she
asked me for orange juice i [ __ ] said
no what was i supposed to say yeah i
didn't want [ __ ] jokes
it's like no it's just the way you said
no you could be like ah you know what
actually i'm good thank you
and i was like oh all right then i
started laughing
and i never forgot that and ever since
then i've tried to do that
so anyway i ended up going to the
wedding i had like
as usual what i was freaking out about
ended up having
a great time you know got out there
got on the dance floor i had a little
couple of cokes i [ __ ] you know
joking around talking to people i had a
[ __ ]
great time i had a great time and i
actually walked out like oh yeah
weddings are fun
you know if you're not a walled off
friggin such a [ __ ] lunatic
so i showed up my suit like an [ __ ]
and i remembered my belt
and then it turned out that my suit
didn't need a belt
and i forgot my cufflinks and a tie and
i was like oh my god i'm a [ __ ] mess
and my wife had to remind me like bill
no one gives a [ __ ] about you this isn't
your wedding okay just [ __ ] show up
nobody's gonna notice and they didn't
they did not so
so there's one for you i've learned that
lesson a zillion times this in your head
you have these [ __ ] mountains
because whatever happened you happened
when you were a kid and it was your
entire universe so it becomes this big
[ __ ] thing in your head
and as an adult you just walk up to it
and it's like stepping up onto a curb
like oh god i thought this was going to
be a no bill you just
show up and have fun i don't know how to
do that
um speaking of of uh it was actually a
great wedding too by the way
it was a great wedding where you're
seeing two people that are supposed to
be together
that love each other that it was really
awesome and then the people that spoke
were great you know
the uh the mc crushed it great dj the
whole thing was just
wired of wire you know
taco station man it was just you know it
really made me
wish i was still drinking but it was
awesome you know there's nothing worse
than going to a [ __ ] wedding
where it's just like these two people sh
what are they thinking
what this is like you know brushing your
teeth
and then having a glass of orange juice
here what are we doing
those weddings are like woof you can
feel it
you can feel the divorce papers hanging
in the air i've been to two of those
and one ended up in divorce and the
other one i think they're still together
um yeah the whoa
man one of them i went to it was just
like i remember when the
the groom was toasting his bride
trying to say why he loved her and he
was like searching for words oh
god oh my god i just want to crawl under
the [ __ ] tape
[Laughter]
um so thank god is there anything better
than going to a [ __ ] wedding getting
out of your own head having a good time
and then seeing two people that love
each other that want to be together it
was [ __ ] awesome i had the best time
um then we hung out for like an extra
half a day
and took my daughter out to uh an
aquarium that they had there
and she had an awesome time and she got
a t-shirt that had a shark that glows in
the dark
so she was all excited i want to wear
this to bed so i could see it glow in
the dark
and uh was a good time good time so
anyway um
speaking of good times i'm coming back
to boston
i'm coming back i'm bill burr i came to
get down i'm coming back to boston
and i am going to uh be doing the wilbur
theater on august 11th it's already sold
out
uh in memory of our great friend wayne
previtty
um giant hole in my heart that will
never be replaced
with him passing um all the uh proceeds
are going to be going to the
american heart association and
uh it's just gonna be awesome it's gonna
be a big reunion the lineup's gonna be a
bunch of comedians that i started out
with
um and i've invited a bunch of comics
like the more comics that i have
available for spots and we're gonna have
some chinese food and all of that [ __ ]
because that's such a big thing
you know the chinese food in new england
is just [ __ ]
it's just next level it's the best
chinese food i've had
other than when i went to china which
was completely different chinese food
which was also amazing which by the way
if you ever go to like
singapore or china and get dumplings
it's just you never knew that something
like that even existed
the dumplings they had at the [ __ ]
airport would be in a five-star
restaurant over here and that was just
their [ __ ] airport dumplings as
opposed to the spot
that everybody goes to but anyways and
i've never done this i got to give a
shout out to chinese people
in boston and
give them their props for what they've
done for stand-up comedy
um an article really needs i don't know
if it's been written probably been
written but like i don't think they ever
got the credit
the entire boston comedy scene started
in a chinese restaurant at the ding ho
where all these amazing comedians lenny
clark
steve sweeney don gavin kenny rogerson
jimmy tingle stephen wright all of these
people
all of these people dennis leary all of
these people started out
tony v frank santarelli
all of these guys started out there and
in this chinese restaurant
and then like this it just works so well
that it just i don't know we have like
stand-up comedy
and chinese restaurants had like this
handshake deal
that you know we'll help you when you
help we'll bring people in here to eat
your food and you let us
stand on stage and and you know
tell our dumb jokes and i did stand up
like so many of my first shows were in
chinese restaurants they had these uh
there was actually a chain
called the akuaku or the akuaku
there was one in worcester and one in
arlington i did a million gigs there i
used to do the cow loon
it was always a chinese restaurant and
stand-up comedy and i love the chinese
especially since i left how great the
food is back there
you know on for some reason around the
country you can't get crab rangoon you
can't get chicken fingers at all it's
specific
new england chinese food and uh so shout
out to chinese people with your
restaurants
in boston if it wasn't for you guys i
wouldn't be here right now
running my yap i don't know because and
that cause another thing too was it was
great stage time where they they never
like
you know they didn't stick you next to
the kitchen where they were cooking
they always had a nice big room it was
closed off
and they would just be coming in
bringing in the food and everything but
it was always like a function room
and uh you could you know if you were on
your game you could have a great set
so uh i don't know i think just going
back
and doing this reunion with all of these
guys and then ordering chinese food for
everybody
made me think of like you know what that
was such a huge like every time i go
back and eat chinese food i just start
thinking about
comedy shows good and bad that i had so
um thank you to the great people that
make that food
and help out all those comics giving us
a stage to work it out
and figure out if we can do something in
this business
so as i mentioned i will be back in
boston so i'm gonna try to do the cardio
every day
as i hit all these spots that i want to
go eat at so
i'm trying to have like a zero week
didn't gain anything didn't lose
anything
but um i don't know i haven't weighed
myself yet since the [ __ ] wedding
because i did eat like an [ __ ] but
i just keep going to the gym and uh
just knocking it out getting it in
getting in and on the weekend i wanted
to go to the gym all three days
but when i got to the hotel our room
wasn't ready and then there was the
rehearsal dinner so i didn't make it on
the first day
i made it on the second day and then
yesterday i was like all right
we'll check out i'll take the kids to
the aquarium and then i'll hit the gym
afterwards you know how that goes you
sit in traffic you're like
[ __ ] it i'll go tomorrow so whatever but
i did get one in
i did get one in and i ate pretty well i
also signed up for mlb
on their website there i signed up for
it uh because now i'm all in with the
red sox
of course i watched we were up three to
nothing in the first inning gave up two
runs in the second inning
and then they got like one and then they
got two runs the next thing you know i
don't know somehow we're not being like
it was like
five to three and then we tie it up and
then we give up a run
let me give up another one last i saw it
was seven to five but some family came
over and i had to say goodbye them so i
think that's how it was
but today at four o'clock the red sox
are playing the rays again which you
guys already know the result of
so i'm all in i'm gonna wash it i guess
the um
[ __ ] uh senators had a fire sale so
did the cubs and i guess we picked up a
picture so we'll see how that goes
speaking of free agents [ __ ]
westbrook
westbrook grows to the [ __ ] lakers
unbelievable
you [ __ ] laker fans how they keep
acting like the 2008 celtics were the
first pile on team it's like dude that
was our reaction
to kobe shack and [ __ ] uh phil
jackson going there come on man you guys
started all of this [ __ ]
i'm so sick of those [ __ ] teams
so i'm rooting for the sons of the
milwaukee bucks and anybody who's not a
pylon team at this point that's my thing
i don't [ __ ]
because i really wasn't into the whole
2008 i mean it was fun that we won it we
beat the lakers with the pylon team
gave them a taste of their own medicine
i thought that that was all right but
other than that
i mean it was weird we were like in last
place and obviously went to first place
the whole thing was just i don't know
maybe i'm just an old guy but i i like
seeing the best players play each other
i know i've said that a thousand [ __ ]
times
so um i think at this point as an nba
fan i am a fan of any team
that is playing the pylon team
that's what it is so we shall see we
shall see what happens
um but the lakers just have too much to
offer
with all the sun and all the [ __ ] out
here uh you just can't compete with them
and they'll just forever be winning
[ __ ]
titles with other people's players i
mean that's what the [ __ ] they do
they've been doing it since they got
[ __ ] kareem
and will chamberlain oh god i'm going in
i'm going in too hard on them that's
[ __ ] because back then
you signed one player whatever i respect
all of the titles except for kobe's
first three i'll give you the last two
okay you know but i
know come on if you're gonna [ __ ]
challenge the 081 i can challenge the
for your last six how about that is that
all right or is this just getting it old
am i just an old man talking in circles
and nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore
is that what it is um
i saw this thing about eagles right this
is literally what i do with my [ __ ]
days now now that i don't drink
i got nothing to do i just i've been
watching the untouchables that series
season three
uh the original one with robert stack
and speaking of lakers i saw one where
diane cannon a young diane cannon
uh crushed it in this episode
um where she worked at like a supper
club and she was a singer and she was
dating
the sort of the mc comic frankie avalon
looking guy
uh who ends up running his yap and ends
up [ __ ] dead in a field
[Laughter]
it's a [ __ ] great episode
um i am all in all [ __ ] in
on the old school untouchables joe
bartnick has been telling me to watch it
for years so
it's a great show just a great show on
me tv
if you guys have it and um
i don't know what else f1 i [ __ ]
missed the race i got to see it i heard
it was an amazing one
and i don't know what happened to max
verstappen but he ended up being in 10th
split place and [ __ ] lewis hamilton
and lewis hamilton comes in third but i
think that
um sebastian vettel's going to get a
penalty so he might
even move up to second place and he
already has sole
possession of first place he leapfrog
past
max verstappen who only got one point so
that makes it like really exciting but i
still have to root for max verstappen
because i feel like
lewis hamilton you know as much as he
endured racism and all that type of
stuff he's won it like a zillion times
and now
he drives for mercedes it's like rooting
for the rich kid
his daddy has the best car he [ __ ]
wins it every year
and then if he doesn't win he cries with
his helmet on so i just can't get behind
that i'm sorry
so i'm rooting for [ __ ] max
verstappen that's my deal
you know and i love those announcers
that do it because anything lewis
hamilton and lewis hamilton
had a pit stop
um he gained an extra point for the
fastest lap
spam spam spam um all right this is it
usually at this point
during the podcast is where i would
actually
uh start to read the advertising but
i've yet to receive it
oh no i guess i did i guess it got sent
in
you know it's [ __ ] just a half-ass
root that roof that really just sucks
when you're a redhead
are those stupid sun sail things
jesus christ what is that
[ __ ] poor attempt why are they shaped
like a [ __ ] triangle
are you trying to block the sun out or
you're just trying to give me
false hope can i buy two of them and
have them interlocked like shoes in a
shoebox so maybe there's a place for a
[ __ ] fair skin
orange [ __ ] like myself to get out of
the global warming of the sun
then you know what happens is the
[ __ ] sun goes down when it starts to
go down
then it's it's like it comes in from the
side and just blasts the side of your
face
i'm telling you dude if if we don't
start turning this [ __ ] around
okay if we don't start making
biodegradable plastic or if we don't
have another big [ __ ] war
and take out a whole bunch of people um
you know which is why if you notice i
didn't bring up any of that coveted
stuff because now i'm rooting for covet
at this point i'm
rooting for the virus i've switched
allegiances
um if it's gonna keep getting [ __ ]
hotter man
you know we got to do something about
these goddamn sun sales we have to use
more of the
earth's natural resources and [ __ ]
you know help out a goddamn redhead you
know what the reality is is i had to
practice what i preach like hey freckles
maybe you're not strong enough to
survive global warming
oh there's another sci-fi movie
right the powers that be all the brown
and black-haired people that you know
with the tv faces that run [ __ ] right
they [ __ ] keep dumping [ __ ] in the
ocean
because everybody knows redheads don't
dump anything in the ocean
this is already going off the rails
whatever this is just i'm just throwing
[ __ ] against the wall here
all right another sci-fi movie
all right maybe somebody animates one of
these things we'll start making billy's
sci-fi movies
all right in a world in about 50 years
the earth is so hot that redheads can no
longer survive
okay as always blondes brunettes and
people with black hair
don't give a [ __ ] so they just go you're
not strong enough to be here
you know what i mean me with my olive
skin my tan skin my skin of color
i can survive with uh sunblock 200
right but the redheads all slowly die
off and nobody cares so then we have to
go underground
right and all the good looking people
the people with the pigment that
everybody loves
they continue to live [ __ ] up the
planet
and eventually everything shuts down
right society the whole [ __ ] thing
and then that's when we come back up out
of the manholes
it's like children of the corn mates
escape from new york
with a touch of golden girls because
there's going to be a bunch of old
people that live under a mountain that
will all we all come together in the end
the redheads in the
blondes brunettes we all go in and we
kill them
the makers are plastic that's what it's
going to be all right
that wasn't the best one there's an idea
in there somewhere
where the you know oh i know it is
redheads feel rejected
right you didn't take it serious until
you started dying of sunburns did you
and you were content to let us all die
off
but what you didn't know is that
redheads hype have a higher threshold
for pain
and we went underground
in the sewage laying underground with
your discarded
exotic pets your reptiles your power
constrictors your alligators
for the last 20 years i've been eating
[ __ ] covered snakes
and alligators and i've come back to get
what's mine
are you with me and all these redheads
then they all come up out of the [ __ ]
manholes
and there's nothing scarier than a group
of redheads together
okay we're just supposed to be like we
add a little color
you know we're supposed to be spliced
together but all of a sudden if there's
just like a group of 20 of us like that
music video
i even found unsettling i even saw it
like what are all those redheads up to
you know i was actually mad at the
redheads that agreed to be in that
do you have any [ __ ] self-esteem you
have no pigment or self-esteem that
you're allowed to you're gonna go
do this [ __ ] video anyway
the only thing scarier than that
assembly of a bunch of redheads
would be a bunch of redheads coming up
out of the sewer that have been [ __ ]
covered [ __ ] pythons for the last 20
years
coming back into society for vengeance
and that's where it picks up you know if
you do the hollywood version the blonde
blue eyeds would [ __ ] well no at this
point they make it a black person
because they want to act like they
weren't the racist white people who
weren't hiring black people just five
years ago
now they're all oh let's make it a
person of color with a
missing limb see we're not
which we can check two boxes
you know that bean counting caring
you don't really change what's in your
heart you just cast what you know will
come back
and bite you in the ass unless you do
something about all the [ __ ] that you've
done before
um anyway let's do the live reads here
okay
headspace everybody headspace man
oh wouldn't it be great if there were a
podcast size guy that helped you
[ __ ] sleep sleep focus act
be better act like you become a better
actor
or behave there is
and if you have 10 minutes headspace can
change your life
headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditation
and an easy to use app headspace is the
only one
of the is one of the only medi
meditation
apps advancing the field of mindfulness
and meditation through clinically
validated research
so whatever the situation headspace
really can help you feel better
overwhelmed headspace has a three-minute
sos
meditation for you need some help
falling asleep no problem
headspace has a wind down session
sessions
their members swear by oh [ __ ] i need
one of those about every 10 minutes
and for parents headspace even has
morning meditations you can do with your
kids
well if you know how to do that you're a
[ __ ] genius you can get a kid to
meditate
jesus christ you can't get him to sit
still headspace's approach to
mindfulness can reduce stress
improve sleep boost focus and increase
your overall sense of well-being
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies
on its benefits six hundred thousand
five star reviews
and over 60 million downloads
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing
meditation practice with mindfulness
that works for you on your schedule
anytime anywhere i gotta do this i've
been wanting to be this person for a
long time
you know rather than flipping out i need
to meditate on this you deserve to feel
happier
and headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com
burr that's headspace.com for a free one
month trial
with access to uh the best
this is the best deal offered right now
uh
headspace head to headspace.com today
i feel like something got cut off there
a free month trial with access
to i imagine meditations that you can
download and listen to
all right and we got one other here oh
look who it is everybody
it's simply safe isn't that how we all
want to feel
i know during this different time during
these
times of change all right simply safe
everybody when simply safe
home security's founders chad
and eleanor lawrence uh
designed their first security system in
their kitchen they did it for a very
personal reason
reason did it for a very personal reason
somebody stole their food man
their friends had just had their home
broken into
they were struggling to find a security
system that was simple to set up
it would make them feel safe again
wait a minute these two people were
cooks
and they and they were able to design a
home security system
how much did they suck at cooking that
they had this skill that they could
become this
this successful or maybe they're just
those people that are good at everything
yeah chad and eleanor i really resent
you too
making people feel safe is what simply
safe has been doing
ever since that moment 15 years ago a
passion to protect people
not only drives every engineering detail
in its products but it motivates every
interaction with its customers
and the thing is simply safe just makes
it so easy
it takes about two minutes to customize
a system on their website
simplysafe.comburr simplysafe has highly
trained security experts ready whenever
you
need them whether that's during a fire a
burglary a medical emergency or even
just when you're setting
up the system there's always someone
there who has your back to keep you safe
and make sure you
feel safe as my listener
this is the privilege you get simply
from listening
to this podcast okay in my uninformed
views
my babblings and and and my just toxic
male way of dealing with things
as my listener you can save 20 on your
simply safe security system
and get your first month free when you
sign up for interactive monitoring
service
just visit simply safe s-i-m-p-l-i
s-a-f-e dot com customize your system
and start protecting your home and
family that's simply safe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
sorry thought i had the same amount of
letters
fe that was one e
um all right
so anyway you look usual you guys like
to write in
you like to say what's going on you you
know
you asked me for advice oh well oh i
haven't
played that in a long [ __ ] time
remember that song
the advice jingle anybody
oh why isn't it playing do i have the
sound down
what do i got to do why i clicked on the
advice
hey that's me
somebody else all right
it is time man it is [ __ ] time when
you guys write in
you know i'm trying to you know trying
to help you out here
you know something that i wish this
younger generation would do more of
i got to tell you as an old fart [ __ ]
comedian
it breaks my heart seeing [ __ ]
stand-up comics going after other
stand-up comics on social media
for the love of god can you guys get
each other's phone numbers and work it
out
you're both comedians you're on the same
[ __ ] team what are we doing
there's enough people coming at
comedians we don't need to be coming at
each other
it kills me ah these kids today these
kids today
what are they doing uh all right british
spelling dear yankee dum-dum nuts
oh jesus christ come on with the ins
dum-dum nuts all right you corrected a
fan for spelling favorite with an o-u
as in f-a-v-o-u-r-i-t
that's the way it's it's that's the way
it's spelt
it that's the way they spell it there
sorry also color
c-o-l-o-u-r is spelled that way
if you don't believe me type it into a
word doc and watch it
not all capitals correct your spelling
listen buddy okay i'm american
all right we don't give a [ __ ] how you
spell it
all right this is how it works you
adjust to us
not the other way around
you know it you know it's true as much
as you guys say you hate us
you can't stop paying attention to us
no one knows the name of your leader
nobody gives a [ __ ]
i'm sure you have the oscars and the
grammys over there your versions of it
and nobody cares they want to win the
one that's here
all right
i if we don't give a [ __ ] about the
world sport do you think i give a [ __ ]
about how you spell
favorite why don't you call something
else brilliant that isn't really
brilliant
now [ __ ] with i had no idea i didn't
know that that's how this i know
you know i know how the canadians spell
canadians
i ens as opposed to ians cause i give a
[ __ ] about hockey i'm sorry
you know i barely know how to spell it
over this way
sorry i'm not a wordsmith all right you
know i know that you guys are over there
you know
you're living over there in england you
know look at you guys look at all you
have to be proud of
almost winning that soccer championship
beating up the fans
defenseless fans five-on-one fights
beating them up
kicking them in the head before the
[ __ ] game you have the nerve to call
us a bunch of fat animals
you know maybe if he got a little fatter
like an american
you wouldn't have enough cardio to boot
the guy in the head for the sixth
[ __ ] time you'd be a little winded
after the first one
all right sorry i didn't mean it did i
mention i'm drinking a smoothie
while i do i'm drinking a smoothie and
i'm in my bare feet
you know l.a didn't get rid of my east
coast edge
um all right well thank you for the
spelling lesson you should probably give
me
reading out loud lessons first before
you try to correct or let me know how
the world spells favorite
um all right unwanted [ __ ] solution
hey billy [ __ ] tits
i don't know why that's so funny [ __ ]
tits is just hilarious
and then you get the alliteration in
there billy [ __ ] you know what i sound
like right now you sound like one of
those guys on the food show
you know when they break down the food
oh so you got the savory and then you
got the sugary and then it comes back to
a savory fungus you get what you [ __ ]
do
okay so you put your onions in there and
then you're gonna caramelize it all
right
wait you putting ice cream on that oh my
god
oh oh that is delicious
um that's what he just did with billy
[ __ ] tits all right i was listening to
your podcast
where you mentioned the unwanted cat in
your driveway uh
uh uh my wife doesn't want it there i
love that [ __ ] cat
kind of ironic that you're looking to
chase [ __ ] away
when you couldn't get it get any for
years
but i guess this is different oh jesus
well you'll be dumped bump there buddy
you didn't even listen you were so
focused on your [ __ ]
joke i guess i said in the end i was
worried that it was gonna you know we
had
you know we had birds those mother bird
you know not in a relationship got
knocked up
you know this [ __ ] horse right and
she had her kids
in the uh in the potted plant you know
father wasn't around absentee father
it's terrible
and that was the only time i didn't like
the cat cause i was like if that thing
goes up there and kills those little
birds in front of my daughter they just
see like couple of bird heads there like
they'll really be
traumatic but i love the cat okay so
with your little
did you see what i did there um any
anyhow
what you need is a lie is lion [ __ ]
serious nature reserves
and zoos sell it for this exact purpose
the cat smells it recognize it
oh ly i thought you meant you need some
lion [ __ ] [ __ ]
you meant literally lion [ __ ]
the cat smells it recognizes it as a
superior specie
and find some other poor schmuck's
driveway to [ __ ] in
dude how big is a lion [ __ ] i mean it's
gonna be [ __ ] that's like a year's
worth of cat [ __ ] why would i do that
i bought some hey this lion took a dump
you want to stick it in your driveway
first of all how does a [ __ ]
domesticated cat
from the united states of america know
what the the apex predator's
[ __ ] smells like in africa
is he going on travel.com on the [ __ ]
weekends i bought some from a safari
park here in the uk
and it worked on my neighbor's cat doing
the same thing on my lawn are you
serious love the podcasts stay off the
donuts [ __ ] the patriots go steelers
well i can see why you say [ __ ] the
patriots if you're a steeler fan but you
know
where where you know tom brady left us
so i don't know where we are now so i
imagine you can finally beat us
but you know what you'll always have to
sit there and realize that you never
beat the new england patriots
in a significant game when tom brady was
here
you know like i didn't take you know
pleasure in when the patriots beating
the steelers
when terry bradshaw wasn't there it felt
good when ben roethlisberger showed up
though
because ben is a man ben is a man he
rides a motorcycle without a helmet god
damn it
um all right let's look up lion
dung for sale
oh god this stuff oh my god
the [ __ ] out of here predator p
mountain lion urine now does this do
this
amazon sells mountain lion piss i mean
jesus
how many [ __ ] people they trying to
put out of business
can of tiger poo oh my god
ah that almost makes me gag can you
imagine working at that [ __ ]
that means like a dumb [ __ ] joke but
seriously
oh my god gross
i guarantee you human [ __ ] still smells
worse
i mean patrice used to joke about that
how human [ __ ] every other [ __ ] was
funny if you stepped in cow [ __ ] you
stepping dog
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] all of it bird [ __ ] all
of it is funny
but the rankist most nastiest [ __ ] out
there is human [ __ ]
uh love it so much
okay this is the review tiger poo love
it so much
funny and kitschy addition to my dining
room
oh so this is okay this is this is a
joke
oh okay love it it was a huge hit put it
on top of my fridge
as a conversation piece boy is it
okay so it's a joke okay i was gonna say
my god it's just pictured somebody with
a giant like
you know like an oar that you row a boat
with just stirring [ __ ] tiger [ __ ]
predator p all right shop
cat deterrent all right homemade
repellent
they're like is this what you're looking
for do you realize i looked up lion [ __ ]
and then like everybody why don't you
just get these [ __ ] things here
uh
no no no let's get back to [ __ ]
mountain lion
piss mountain lion urine you can buy it
on amazon
predator p
um well wait a minute there's a mountain
lion in my [ __ ] neighborhood now what
if i
spray this [ __ ] and i go from a small
cat i can deal with to a bigger [ __ ]
cat
i can't go mountain lion p this mountain
lion thinks he has a chance i gotta go i
gotta go lion pee right
mountain lion urine territorial marking
scent creates illusion that a mountain
lion is nearby
reduced okay let's let's see
does mountain lion
urine attract mountain lions here we go
it's right there
somebody uh by liberally marking an
area with mountain lion p you duplicate
the territorial marking
habits of mountain lions in the wire
this illusion
triggers an instinctive response in prey
if mountain lion's scent is around these
animals
want to be far away but what about
mountain lions
what about mountain lions
ah jesus christ [ __ ] rabbit hole you
[ __ ] sent me down
does mountain lion yeah does it attract
other [ __ ] mountain lions
predator odors attract other predators
yeah see look at me openly common sense
here
put it in order to attract other
creating an olfactory web
of information
many studies have reported the aversive
reactions of prey
towards a predator's odor uh
urine a behavior widely thought to
reduce the risk of
predation by the predator however
because odor signals
persist in the environment they are
vulnerable to exploitation and
eavesdropping by predators prey
in con specifics i have no idea what i'm
reading right now
as such scent patches created by one
species might attract another species
interested in
information about their enemies we study
this you know what
you know what this is called this is
classic white people [ __ ]
where i'm gonna create and i'm going to
solve a small problem
by creating an an even bigger problem
and a very brilliant person said to me
one time said human beings
are the only people that don't adapt to
nature they try to make nature adapt to
them and we start [ __ ] with the
matrix i'm not [ __ ] with the matrix
okay i can deal with the house cat
i'm not [ __ ] [ __ ] taking lion [ __ ]
first of all i couldn't even find it let
me look it up again
because i know the person who said well
i didn't say mountain lion p i said lion
[ __ ]
lion poo poop for sale
you can get it in the uk oh god you guys
are [ __ ] cultured out there aren't
you
all right the only true socially big cat
lion poo for sale you can't buy this
[ __ ] watch german circus sells giant
sells jars of lion poop for gardening
at least they're recycling does lion poo
really keep cats away here we go
here we go all right
if you have a beautiful garden that
you're proud of you probably spent a lot
of time in that garden in fact you
probably spent most of the weekends what
the [ __ ] are we talking about your
garden for
oh jesus christ
okay now that being said there are also
times when gardening can be
get stressful this is especially true if
you are battling cats or other small
animals
i don't know cats [ __ ] up gardens
these mammals not only like to get into
the garden and eat your plants and
flowers but they like to leave you
little presents everywhere in the form
of scat
see that i think there's a reason why
cat is in the word
scat now one might think that animal
scat is good a good fertilizer but that
isn't the case at all
in fact it might well now you're talking
about a garden
lion poo the first thing you know is
that lion
dung is solid online
is so stuff it's solid
lion dung is sold online in pellets and
there are a number of individuals that
have boasted about this product
everything it has to offer why lion poo
might work why lime poo might not work
you know what dude this is too early in
the process
i'm not gonna be a guinea pig
and [ __ ] have some lion poo or some
goddamn bear urine
and all of a sudden uh you know i opened
the door you know
and whatever that i sprayed out there
you know somebody's looking for a suitor
it's not happening okay not my world
all right you can take your [ __ ] lion
poo you can send it right back to the
[ __ ] jungle you found it in because i
ain't gonna buy it
all right childhood snack
hey dear billy bottom [ __ ] burr
i have a question for you that goes back
to the days where you are not allowed to
touch the thermostat
but before i ask the question i have a
story on why i am
so interested uh my dad told me a story
about one of his favorite childhood
snacks
it was something called a wish sandwich
they wrote a whole song about that
you wish you had some meat okay the
ingredients to the wish sandwich are two
slices of bread
mustard and you wishing that there was
meat and cheese to go along with it
my dad's family grew up very poor and
this would be all that they would eat
for a meal at rough times yes the
condiment sandwich
the worst of meals being crackers and
ketchup
they still laugh about it every now and
then
uh and then they have a wish sandwich to
remember their childhood
so i got in the habit of asking people
their favorite childhood snack or meal
would you be surprised by some you would
be surprised by some people's
answers so i thought i would ask a fatty
like yourself
what was your favorite childhood snack
or meal thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
um my favorite childhood
snack ah do everything
everything i've already talked to you
about stakehomes that's when i felt like
i was becoming an adult
when i would come home and i would make
myself a steakhum
which was paper-thin beef from some sort
of animal
that was like frozen and then you'd put
it in the pan
and when it became like see-through and
brown you'd flip it over then you put a
little cheese on top
and then you stick it on some white
bread and try to eat it before all the
grease made it all
soak in wet bread there was those i like
as far as like junk food goes i like
fritos
still my all-time favorite chip is a
frito
uh i never made the leap to doritos i
just don't like them
the original the winter winter green
whatever they got every [ __ ] flavor
doritos ice zimas
doritos i don't like any of them i like
fritos
i used to like bugles um
i don't know if i'd be into those too
much now but i i i like doritos
uh as far as cookies go
all right i like oreo cookies i do like
double stuff
i like the blonde oreos i really like
oreos
uh
and everything else i don't know
everything else can go [ __ ] itself as
far as cookies go
unless you just make like a homemade one
but like i don't eat that [ __ ] right now
i gotta wait till i get in shape again
so then i become a fat [ __ ] again when i
eat all that crap
um let's see what else
i liked um cereal
back in the day i liked boo berry
i like to count chocula even though i'm
a ginger i still didn't like frank and
berry
liked uh shredded wheat with like a
pound of sugar on it
um i liked corn flakes
raisin bran cheerios and then when i
became an adult
if i was gonna treat myself to a cereal
that i shouldn't be eating it was
cinnamon life
and then as far as like those [ __ ]
baked
like cake pre-caked [ __ ] things
uh twinkies can go [ __ ] themselves
devil dogs can go [ __ ] themselves
uh twinkies because they don't taste
like anything devil dogs because they're
[ __ ]
as dry as anything i've ever had in my
[ __ ] life
um hostess cupcakes weren't that bad
i like those they they at least weren't
dry
but i wasn't into yodels or any of that
[ __ ] i don't like a lot of the cakes man
um but as far as like growing up you
know
you know we we had money then we didn't
have money then we had a little money
and then i moved out so like
we sort of always were like chip beef on
toast
chicken ala king uh hungarian goulash
we ate all of that [ __ ] pork chops
occasionally
cube steaks as you guys know you know
the [ __ ] 70s me
that wasn't even considered [ __ ] poor
food
it was just you know i told you
until i hang out with black people i
thought macaroni and cheese was a
[ __ ]
main dish that's what we we ate it as a
main dish
like we were having pasta my mother
would [ __ ] take out like you know
four little those little [ __ ] tv
dinner crates of them
heat them up in the oven then you'd peel
off the top and then you just heat them
up in the oven and then you just throw
it in a bowl and everybody would eat
them we'd have it with toast
and it was delicious um all right
animosity towards my fiance
oh boy oh boy here we go
here comes somebody maybe needs to pull
the plug there first off let's sit
set things straight here all right
you are a funny [ __ ] i [ __ ]
with you
uh i [ __ ] with you tough you are the
funniest comedian out there
i like this person nothing my
compliments not holding me accountable
for my actions
nothing but you know praise now let me
get off your nuts because i know people
tell you this [ __ ] all the time um
doesn't mean i don't like to hear it so
thank you i have a i have a life story
to tell you about let's see how this
goes
i've been with my girl now since
november 2018.
you're a pilot do the math
all right well it's two and a half years
i mean i don't think that has anything
to do with flying a plane uh rewind it's
september
1st 2018 my father passed away
sorry to hear that i'm a wreck my girl
at the time who i was with
for six years who i adored loved never
cheated on
treated her like the [ __ ] queen i
thought she was
leaves me a month after my dad dies
oh dude that means she wanted to dump
you before and then she was just like
[ __ ] his dad died now i got to hang
around for another month
god damn it uh it was a blessing in
disguise because she was one of those
girls that liked
that like to hit oh yeah
my wife used to be like that she used to
[ __ ] throw [ __ ] and punch me
lunatic she used to call it i'm
passionate
uh she was a narcissist controlling as
hell also
found out she cheated on me oh jesus you
[ __ ] dodged a bullet there sir
so now i'm a double wreck feeling lost
and heartbroken at this point
hey i have feelings [ __ ] this is
typical guys like he i'm feeling
heartbroken
he couldn't just say that he had he had
to throw a [ __ ] you across the bow to
keep me at bay here
uh not even a week later this amazing
woman amazing all capital letters woman
just falls into my lap
so what do i do after all
yeah yeah [ __ ] what does she do i
tell her i'm not ready for a
relationship
i tell her that she's a good woman and
she doesn't deserve how i'm gonna treat
her
parentheses like [ __ ] i told her i know
how i am and i don't want to treat her
horribly just because
my last relationship ended so wrong that
was a mature thing
to know about yourself uh i wasn't ready
you know the dust must settle
and the debris must be thrown out from
the wreckage of the last relationship
yes uh my girl now insisted on staying
with me
to help me go no my girl now this woman
same person insisted on staying with me
to help me go through my tough time
i didn't wanted to i wanted to be myself
constantly trying to push her away
i wanted time to focus on me that didn't
happen valentine's day came around i
tried to break up with her that night
but when i told her we couldn't see one
another the waterworks came
and i gave into the tears and she got
her way now
fast forward about a year we have a
beautiful baby girl together oh my
goodness
january 25th 2020. congratulations i
hope
uh we're a family as we should be we
plan on getting married in september
2021.
where is the problem uh
i feel animosity towards my fiancee for
never giving me the chance
to breathe i haven't been able to
mentally place myself into this
relationship
i feel like i used all my good energy on
the wrong person in my last relationship
now where now we're getting married with
a little girl and i still feel the same
it's not fair for such an amazing woman
like her to be with a damaged man like
myself
i want to get back to normal and be able
to mentally check into this relationship
finally i'm questioning getting married
right now
i'm so confused and still feel lost any
advice
would be wonderful go [ __ ] yourself um
all right um i don't think you you're
holding yourself accountable for your
actions here
all right you knew from day one you
didn't want to be with this woman and
you needed your space
all right and you keep blaming her like
she pulled you in
like you didn't have the power to say no
you broke up with her on the evening of
valentine's day
all right she starts crying and rather
than sticking to your guns you stayed
into it
and now you have a kid with her so
what i would do if i was you is stop
blaming her and feeling resentment
towards her
he should actually be questioning what
is wrong with you
that you didn't want to be in something
you got into it and now you're you have
a kid and you're going to get married
you need to go to therapy
is what i would do i would go to therapy
and be like hey tell her what
him or her you talking to what you just
did and try to figure out
why you do that stuff rather than
blaming this woman who you say is an
amazing woman
who you know you have a kid with um
but to give you something positive here
you know in case you think i'm coming
down on you
um this is a part of life part of life
is blaming other people for decisions
that you made
until one day you hold yourself
accountable
like what am i contributing to this
situation
you know why what happened to me that
made me
once a woman cried give in and most guys
do give in when that happens
um i've done both
and i'll tell you it never works out
either way
i've called him on really you're gonna
cry about this how old are you that
that never ends well you're so cold
uh pregnant woman's rights dear billy
vanilli
ice cream sandwich love and birth oh
guilty is [ __ ] charged
vanilla ice cream billy vanilli ice
cream sandwich love and burr i like that
one
i recently saw a visibly pregnant woman
smoking
hey man it's her kid i couldn't believe
with all the information we know about
tobacco that this still occurs
so i made a post about it on facebook
talking about how if we can smash a
window
to get a dog out of a car why can't we
smack the cigarette out of a pregnant
woman's mouth that's [ __ ] hilarious
oddly this didn't go well i know you're
being sarcastic
and became a discussion about women's
rights to her anatomy
i am pro-choice but smoking while
pregnant should be regarded as child
abuse
what are your thoughts on this liberals
gone wild moment
uh i hope you were having a great go
[ __ ] yourself
whatever that means um
well yeah dude if you post something
like that on the internet you think some
[ __ ] morons aren't going to jump on
the hook and start yelling at you i
think it was
i think it's a great joke that's what i
think i think it's a really good joke
and i think you should continue
doing jokes like that because i think
it's funny
and um
i can tell you right now if men carried
the baby
and we smoked a woman would have every
right to slap it out of our mouths
that's my baby too and they would do it
and you know what they'd be right they'd
be right
okay she's making decisions for someone
who doesn't
have the ability to make a decision an
unborn child i mean jesus christ you
know
but as i've learned throughout the years
that they
they women are when you're in a
relationship and then you're married and
there's a kid and everything they
are number one they are the starting
quarterback
it's them then the kids then
you know whatever the [ __ ] going on in
the house and then you that's how it
[ __ ] works
that's how the pyramid is built so it
doesn't surprise me that a small number
of psycho women are arguing that but i
don't believe
that most women
feel that and i don't think that people
really think you want to go up and slap
it out of her mouth
what you should do is get a spray bottle
of water and put it on the
the most widest like you know so it hits
her in the face too
oh what are we doing put that out
there's a baby in there
you're welcome skip away
and you just do it water you know water
is all natural
most people are dehydrated so it's in
smoking makes you dehydrated so there
you go right
there look what i did see what it did i
saved your baby
and hydrated your breast to this how
could you be that mad at me
i moisturized your face while you know
helping helping your unborn baby like
what could be the problem
who knows all right that is the podcast
everybody i'm gonna go watch the uh red
sox just started
playing the devil race i'm gonna record
that i'm gonna actually go swimming with
my kid
that's what i told her i was gonna do
and i have to do it
um because uh
you know eventually they're not going to
want to do it that's why you know
eventually they're going to get like
right now she has a tablet and that
[ __ ] thing
is just like it's really cutting into
daddy daughter time so
we got to like you know dude you get
your kid like any sort of computer or a
phone or anything like that it's like
giving a crackhead crack
you immediately have a problem all of a
sudden you can't get them to answer your
questions look at you or anything like
that so i gotta make sure
i put in the quality time so that is it
everybody um thank you to everybody that
bought tickets
to the wayne pretty uh benefits slash
um memorial slash reunion
i'm very excited to get back there um
and eat all that delicious food so i'm
going to keep going on the elliptical
bliptical burr um i'm also you know
lifting the weights dead throwing them
around
i did the old legs and eggs today my
favorite thing that the [ __ ] leg room
dude i'll tell you man
word is out about legs the leg room the
last couple times i've gone in there has
been packed
usually the loneliest part of the room
is the [ __ ] squat rack and all of
that [ __ ] but lately
people have been in there they're not
like the guys i remember back in the day
a squat rack was something to hang your
[ __ ]
your [ __ ] champion hoodie on as you
benched for the ninth day in the [ __ ]
row
all right that's it everybody go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll check in on you on
thursday